getting one-on-one time with tanya it's
quite nice
i just wanted to actually make her feel
comfortable being with us
as a family but i feel concerned about
actually what's happening in central's
life and what the future still holds
how do you actually feel about being
here in south africa again
i feel good i'm happy you know it sucks
that dylan
you know dylan's knees what happened but
i'm happy that brought us here you know
i know it's engine's homesick but
yeah but does he seem happy then he
seems happy i think so
i feel like i compromised like the
beginning of our relationship i did a
lot of things i would have never done
and now i'm asking him like to settle
down i i think he wants to but part of
him feels like he's losing his freedom
i'm like i don't want you to feel like
you're losing your freedom like being
committed
or in a relationship with me
does it feel like you want to change
sinjin no i don't think so
but it's just sometimes like it's just
the partying it's like i'm not like i
was
i'm like i partied hard when i was 21
you know i'm
like done with that and so i call him
out on it
[Music]
i think that both of them have their
flaws and shenzhen
finds it a bit difficult to settle down
but as well
with tanya that would be maybe a bit
controlling so i think they can both
work on
certain things
[Music]